sumemos 6 entre 2 x al cuadrado menos 7
más menos 3 x menos ocho entre 2 x al
cuadrado menos 7 y como siempre ponle
pausa del vídeo e intenta resolverlo por
tu cuenta lo que estamos viendo aquí es
que tenemos estas dos expresiones
racionales que tienen el mismo
denominador 2 x al cuadrado menos 7
aunque podemos decir que tenemos 62 x al
cuadrado menos 7 a vos
y menos 3 x 8 2 x al cuadrado menos 7 a
vos esta podría ser una forma de pensar
en esto pero el punto es que si tenemos
el mismo denominador esto va a ser igual
y aquí lo único que tenemos que hacer es
tomar ese mismo denominador 2 x cuadrado
menos 7
y sumar los numeradores así es que por
aquí vamos a tener un 6
más o menos 3 x menos 8 menos 3 x menos
8 y si queremos simplificarlo un poco
podemos ver que podemos juntar el 6 y el
menos 8 y 6 más menos 8 es menos 2
tenemos por aquí un -2 y aquí estamos
sumando un 3x negativo o sea que estamos
restando 3x y el denominador es 2 x al
cuadrado menos 7 y listo ya terminamos
ya sumamos estas dos expresiones
racionales y bueno ya que terminamos
vamos a hacer otros ejercicios aquí lo
que queremos es restarle una expresión
racional a otra así es que intenta ver
si puedes resolver esto bueno pues
nuevamente estas dos expresiones
racionales tienen exactamente el mismo
denominador tienen el denominador 14 x
al cuadrado menos 9 por lo tanto el
denominador de esta resta también va a
ser 14 x al cuadrado menos 9
es el denominador de estas dos
expresiones racionales que se están
restando por lo tanto el resultado va a
tener el mismo denominador 14 x al
cuadrado menos 9 así es que podemos
simplemente restar los numeradores
tenemos aquí 9 x al cuadrado más 39 x al
cuadrado más 3 - menos todo el numerador
de acá que es menos 3 x al cuadrado más
5 y aquí lo que tenemos que hacer es
distribuir este signo negativo nos queda
9 x al cuadrado más 39 x al cuadrado más
3 y aquí distribuyendo el signo negativo
menos menos 3 x al cuadrado menos con
menos nos da más y nos queda simplemente
3x al cuadrado aunque ya si es que aquí
tenemos que sumar 3 x al cuadrado y
luego menos más 5 nos queda simplemente
menos 5
-5 y estamos dividiendo a todo esto
entre 14 x al cuadrado menos 9 14 x al
cuadrado menos 9 y ahora podemos
simplificar un poco el numerador aunque
porque tenemos aquí 9 x al cuadrado más
3 x al cuadrado y eso es igual a 12 x al
cuadrado y finalmente tenemos por aquí
un 3 más menos 5 aunque hay menos 5 y 3
menos 5 es menos dos menos dos y todo
esto se divide entre 14 x al cuadrado
menos 9 y listo ya terminamos ya
restamos estas dos expresiones
racionales y bueno claro por aquí
podemos empezar a pensar en otras cosas
por ejemplo podemos tratar de
simplificar esta expresión racional
podemos preguntarnos oye no habrá por
aquí algún factor común y bueno ambos
van a ser una diferencia de cuadrados
pero estas de aquí son diferencias de
cuadrados distintas por lo
no van a tener ningún factor común si es
que finalmente esto sí es lo más
simplificado que podemos obtener